oh
dayton hypernova make another video we
have to check in with them time to time
make sure he hasn't murdered his family
he beats me and i may only make a
hundred dollars a week for my favorite
right my free house so you've seen this
video oh no i just assumed
every one of his videos
um not for any particular reason
other than um my older brother
who beats me like over twice my size
we know um his bedroom door is wide open
right now oh my god that sounds
terrifying he never leaves it open i
mean sometimes it's open slightly but
it's never wide open
so it's the first time i walked by the
door
look at this pterodactyl claws for hands
too all right to his bedroom
and saw his wall that's like right next
to the door
like i never looked that far into his
room when i'm walking by normally
because it's
a wall that's kind of away from
my peripheral vision when i'm walking by
so he's
like he never looks straight he's always
looking off to the side
so here's what [ __ ] homies gonna do
what's on the wall
what's on the wall it's not really like
a shrine
he's now gonna go sneak into his room
and film him like him
having thought he has photos of like
all this nonsense boxing stuff he never
succeeded in boxing
i don't think that he's ever had a
successful boxing whoa
first of all how dare you
so what you mean to tell me is that he
went out and tried at boxing and failed
at it
that's a hundred times more than you've
done
hey he has psoriasis but like
yeah it's it's not uncommon for somebody
who
pursued a thing they were passionate
about even if they failed that thing
to still follow that thing passionately
right is that no of course
a lot of guys that run little boxing
gyms in in the inner city that never
really made it as a boxer but they're
you know but they're successful
golden gloves posters up on the wall
yeah if i don't know that he's ever had
a professional match in his entire life
as far as boxing he used to live in
l.a like when he was in his
mid to late 20s during the big la boxing
boom
yeah that was huge it was [ __ ] huge
or no he
lived there for a while because i think
he didn't move home until
could you imagine having this creep
telling your life story all the time on
video every day like
that's my point i would beat you up too
exactly and mike these videos go back
all the way to 2014.
he's been doing this for like 200 people
since
2014. his mid-30s so i guess he lived
out there for a while
but yeah i can't be too loud because
he's downstairs i don't want him here
i don't want to walk by his room with a
camera just to show
that like mantle to himself he hasn't
you imagine if you walked like and
somebody was just filming your room
telling me this ends with a beating no
because his brother doesn't actually
beat him
i know but it would be great if this
video finally ended with one
this guy i just want to walk by
this okay he has swords
his brother does have three swords he
has three samurai swords
and by the way that that set of three
little
decorative swords i've seen have you
probably seen that everywhere
that thing's advertised everywhere it's
cheap shitty it's just like decorative
but his
it's still gay his brother is basically
mac
from always sunny no that's what he is
karate
all right so here's a world boxing uh
like a replica belts
like a replica belt for wbc which
honestly
people that collect replica belts or
cringe as [ __ ] there is something mildly
less cringe about this though than like
people that have the wrestling belts
yeah yeah i would agree something mildly
less uh
cringe
that's him right there in that picture
so what
it's weird yeah but like i look i make
fun of people that put pictures of
themselves up in their bedroom to me
it's
just weird well i think he put him up
he's putting him up with people that he
knows and i
i that's it's it's not like look it's
not just the pictures
yeah i guess you're right it's still
weird in your bedroom it's it's one
thing to have pictures of you with other
various people up on your desk or your
right workspace but
people who put pictures of themselves up
in their room are weird
that being said hey uh hey earl who the
[ __ ] are you
telling you about weird who the [ __ ] are
you to tell anybody
what to do and then when i talk back
they go
crazy at me so those are the only times
they ever say they go crazy
we saw you yelling at your mom after
stealing her credit card
that poor old man while you're just
trying to eat his egg salad sandwich
yeah [ __ ] chilling out oh this guy's the
worst it's the worst human being ever
in front of them so i guess because
they're so angry they don't think about
it
i don't know i just play real
cool around these people because yeah
you were always playing a real
cool cool as a cucumber yeah i was gonna
say you know that earl schultz he's a
real
cool customer
chris obviously he's really dangerous
and i mean bob johnson says he has the
jim norton wall of people i've met
that's so true [ __ ] norton has a
picture a [ __ ]
a whole section of his house that's
right picture's just famous people
oh god it's so crazy well you know he
probably let's be fair if he didn't make
it with o a
yeah he would have been live with his
parents absolutely with that wall with
the swords
the black sabbath album cover and
a couple pictures of him with people oh
that's a [ __ ] weird life to have in
your 50s
he's lived here six years the only
reason i haven't gotten out of here by
now is because of my psoriasis
and this year my stress isn't too bad
because i got so he's talking [ __ ] about
his brother still living there
even though he's still living there
still beats me and he berates me you
know there's people that are missing
limbs that have jobs your psoriasis is
not a reason not to have a job earl
no preferably not a food industry call
center
call center call center works yeah i've
gotten
i've received treatment at the
dermatologist a couple times this year
so far
or in the past six months i'm supposed
to get treatment again next month and i
hope it goes fine because i'm at the
mercy of those doctors
who don't want to even treat me because
of my income being
below poverty level okay so they don't
want to treat you for free they don't
want to give you free stuff no they
don't
okay that's how dare they
so that's terrible i mean i live in a
nice house but the people who
i live with my parents uh they make
plenty of money uh they're upper middle
class
and i mean they're not upper middle
class errol
they're not upper middle class and by
the way
earl even if they were wealthy that's
not exactly that's not the point
how dare you they're by the way they're
not the dad that we've we've seen the
videos
and we've had family members email us
they'd live off the social
security they only have one car because
they could only afford to have one car
yeah and let's say they own that house
right i know people at that income
bracket they're barely holding on to
that house
they're just paying their bills they
might have a little bit of cash stored
away but they're not talking about
rich people or upper middle class people
which
that's that's a certain title that you
people clearly are not this guy's a
[ __ ] i hate this dude you refuse to pay
me minimum wage see somebody wrote yeah
dayton ohio upper middle class
yeah that's good okay fair that's fair
that's that's hilarious sorry people
from dayton
sorry you're poor seriously
i'm just kidding i'm not sorry you're
poor
what some people have to be poor i don't
want to like you want to be you no of
course not
thanks dayton thanks dave thank you very
cool
very cool that's why i love flint
michigan i don't want to drink poison
water and they do it so then the law of
averages
we get our water is great actually we
have good water we have a bunch of
poison water so
thank you flint thank you poor people
for being poor so we don't have to oh
[ __ ]
they say they pay me plenty they know
uh their estimate of remember that they
pay him a hundred dollars a week to do
their laundry and he eats their food
he sleeps in their house and he gets
paid on it and he gets paid a hundred
dollars to do which isn't enough
no it's not even a minimum wage how much
they pay me is based on
what their average in their mind is of
uh
one hour each day not including the
weekends
anyway so it's only five days of the
week in their mind okay so i have
another video this guy that i really
really wanted to please man
this is clumsy martian has a really good
just get a job if you want to stop being
poor
i will check this out i haven't eaten
half a meal today my parents got home
after leaving their house all day to a
bigot's son
little wordy his titles are a little
long but check this one out
go downstairs and tell my mom that i've
been starving all day
that there's no food left in the freezer
for me
so let me get this straight earl they
buy your food too
so they also buy his food okay corley's
there's very little left all right you
know what i just figured it out and
everybody
now is not going to be able to unsee
this this guy looks like gary sharon
hold on he was the third the third
singer of van halen
yes i remember hold on it looks like it
looks like gary sharon i've been it's
been bothering me
for it's been bothering me since we've
been watching date night i'm like which
80s rock guy does he look like it's been
bombed oh yeah
he looks like gary sharon he does
he does
and i've been starving all day eating
with very little left in that freezer so
that's right
you don't buy any of the food earl okay
and i'm light-headed so i'm going
downstairs
and telling her i need food because
she's been gone all day her and dad have
been somewhere all day and they just got
back and it's only it's so
so you're upset that your parents are
living their retired life and going out
and doing things
yeah like look i know we [ __ ] on the
boomers right
for being shitty about like the stuff
they do
but we're not we've never said that
boomers shouldn't indulge a little bit
like you're retired you're supposed to
enjoy some of it we just talked about
the ones that like
make sure they liquidate everything and
spend every penny and go [ __ ] my kids
but
you know at the same time they they're
allowed to uh
enjoy their retirement it's the point
it's like i don't have to work anymore
i'm not saying take a cruise every week
but yeah once in a while we'll go on a
cruise you're old you get to get [ __ ]
buffet shrimp
and get drunk on a boat you kind of
earned it right
oh it's almost 11 at night
and they've been gone since i've been
awake
so it's been like the entire day
and i've been in this house with my
older brother who beats me and he's been
a
prick so i don't like to be around him
stay upset i just stay upstairs to
myself and i run down to the basement to
do
laundry which i get paid very little for
you get a hundred dollars a week to do
laundry which is not
bad at all and considering you're not
paying rent
you wouldn't make a hundred dollars a
week working at an actual wash and fold
yeah
doing laundry i go downstairs and tell
her i need
to eat tonight so
so now this is the stuff that really
that he secretly now films these
conversations
he hides the phone now watch he wants
food that's the ongoing theme here
i think he's washing his hands here
okay here you go
i have no food left well
sherman's gonna go to the store tonight
yeah that's what he said does he know
that he needs to get food
huh does he know that he needs to get
food he doesn't know anything
i told him gluten-free burritos
oh my god with this guy so he also has
dietary
yes and he thinks gluten-free burritos
are his health food
on top of all that gluten-free burritos
are healthy
like frozen burritos ripe is gluten-free
the gluten is not what makes someone
healthy you idiot
i mean don't get me wrong frozen
burritos sound dope right now yeah
but you're not gonna eat those and go
health food this guy's the worst
and they're also more expensive and it's
just like like this
and he's not paying for them and he's
not paying for them get me this
she doesn't know what she's talking
about and this is fruit infuriating
so i don't know what to do i have a
couple of ideas
i got i got a couple too yeah you
probably think they're the same
no you go first uh well there's a couple
of ideas right
don't and i'm guilty of this sometimes
but uh if you don't have
money uh don't wait till 11 o'clock
and then go what am i going to eat
tonight that's a good one that's a good
one
don't rely on other people's food supply
to survive and and and you know if you
make a hundred bucks a week
get some even if it's some ramen noodles
stash them around you got them
if you're in a jam uh also
i don't know maybe stop being a bum yeah
just in general just leave
my idea involved but i mean yours is
different than mine
in minecraft i don't you know just to be
safe but it's like so many layers of
your responsibility like yeah
i have to depend on your food supply uh
but now i'm also gonna wait until 11 p.m
to say i also want gluten-free burritos
he dean goes
if he's hungry he can eat a pecker there
you go
i don't know why pecker made it so funny
he's not going to get anything that he's
talking that she tells him
he's going to pick up something random
i don't specifically eat gluten-free
burritos so i don't know where she gets
that from
i don't know what to say to her what do
you eat what do you eat health food
he eats health food brewery specially
made
from the health store like what are
health food burritos
they're burritos that are health they're
from two years thing right you take a
burrito right
and then you mark it up 50 okay and you
market it as a
healthier burrito that's basically what
it is
i eat health food burritos
that would be the code word to get into
one of those swingers parties you said
earlier
dude man i i don't oh
this guy oh [ __ ] health food burritos
she's very infuriating because she
doesn't communicate with me but she
communicates plenty with him
and he is a narcissist who abuses her
verbally
so he's the narcissist he abuses her
verbally he does
is he also the one that stole her credit
card it's like
a very disturbing narcissistic
relationship between those two
and they both harass me he beats me and
she harasses me
right in front of she harasses me while
he's beating me and that's what happens
so while he's hitting you with a stick
she's going and another thing
she seems like that they all seem like
they're they seem like terrible
people yeah on the floor in this house
and
she was going off at me or just being
really sarcastic about me being in a
dress while he was beating me down
and after four years of recording him
now there's still not one video of his
brother beating him down
now again from what i've heard sherman
is also a bum
yeah i mean what people are winners but
i was told that
sherman is appreciative apparently for
his situation he's
actually like he's nice with his parents
you know he
he doesn't look a little lazy videos
actually like pretty much show he's kind
of a bum but he's like uh
like he you just we'll go out to dinner
and be a normal boss be a normal guy
yeah
not make a [ __ ] scene and be like oh
baby it's me